for the first time we are seeing images
of two of the four US soldiers killed by
Islamic militants in the African nation
of Nigeria last October newly released
video from national Geographics chain of
command shows sergeant lee david johnson
and star sir ben staff sergeant rather
dustin right with their unit which also
lost two other soldiers in the battle
David Martin is at the Pentagon with
this story David good morning good
morning the military's investigation
into the ambush has now been delivered
to the Secretary of Defense for final
review and is expected to be released to
the public sometime in March anybody can
shoot a gun yeah
demos something else it's a lot more fun
Staff Sergeant Dustin Wright
demonstrates how his team detonates
weapon
while Sergeant David Johnson full of
life does backflips sings and jokes with
the Nigerian soldiers his team was
trained on Johnson's full-time job was
as a mechanic but he did double duty as
a barber there's something you haven't
been able to fix or do that you've been
asked to do on this trip just three
weeks later on October 4th Johnson right
and two other soldiers were ambushed and
killed by terrorists Johnson's body was
not recovered for two days which speaks
volumes two retired Brigadier General
Donald bull doc the former commander of
special operations in Africa there was
most likely an element of surprise that
the patrol was overwhelmed very quickly
defending your country's special forces
were in Nazaire to train the local
troops who according to their commander
were chasing roaming bands of terrorists
as Aryans and their American advisers
headed out on what was supposed to be a
simple reconnaissance patrol but halfway
through the Patrol the Special Forces
were given another mission check out a
camp site where a wanted terrorist had
been spotted a few days earlier going
after and checking out an area that a
high-value target has just been in would
be a you know high-risk mission at a
memorial service one of their commanders
said that as the team was running out of
ammunition and about to be overrun they
sent out a distress call once used
during the Vietnam War Broken Arrow
Noora all right David thank you so much